Gary Vaynerchuk one of the cofounders of
empathy wines
and we are tasting the new empathy wines
2019 with uh with one of the individuals
that is so integral to the success right
there mr. Tom Rowan pretty excited about
that he'll be joining us shortly and
some others from the empathy community
if you are not part of the empathy
family empathy wines calm right now we
would love for you to join us please
become a club member where you get a
subscription of our beautiful white our
red comes out to fall and the Rose a
comes later we have a whole system you
might have also seen yesterday that we
transacted on this business remedy wines
was sold to Constellation Brands
yesterday you might have seen some of
the headlines and that is a pretty
exciting for Johnny and skew nor in the
rest of the team big transaction in my
career and we're really excited about
that and so the timing this was
scheduled for quite a while the
announcement scheduled wasn't for was
very fluid given the world we live in
covetous any other things so really fun
timing for me as well from the business
side and from the wine side Dustin is
here Dustin you say hello hello yes
Edgar this does sell in California but
it's a direct-to-consumer you can't get
in stores and restaurants so empathy
wines that calm Dustin
how are you excellent good do we have
our guests lined up yep
tom is ready to grow and so is everyone
else good timing here cool how's it
going cheers brother
cheers i celebratory triggers for you I
guess good timing
double cheers for me no question why
don't you tell everybody about yourself
one of the as you know and we're very
grateful to have the partnership with
you one of the big factors in this
project and I think you know this
there's there's we've seen in the wine
world people come along start brands
with extremely super uber famous or
leveraged vineyards and there
a siphon the leverage one of the reasons
we started this was we wanted to give
some of the best growers farmers that we
loved even a bigger platform you don't
see a whole lot of people doing stuff
like this in our world so I'm very
humbled for you to be here and and
really hope that the empathy project can
help your business to be break Oh
totally so just a little background
about myself I'm a seventh generation
farmer in the greater Sacramento regions
say that one more time I'm a seventh
generation farmer outside and my niece
will be the eighth if she decides to
decide to be a farmer and the greater
Sacramento area and we we've been
farming in the Clarksburg region which
is an AV a an American food culture area
or over a hundred years so I did
something you probably have advised many
many many of your followers to do a
little over a year ago I direct messaged
empathy wines it be a Instagram
instead a I love what you guys are doing
and there's ever any way for me to be a
part of this brand insta flying grapes
Chardonnay and Chenin Blanc I just love
to be a part of it so and now I'm here
and you've uh you and your team have
done an excellent job at at doing
something extremely differ in the wine
industry I appreciate that
let's talk about that actually cuz I
know the majority of the people are
watching it work team don't worry I'll
go into like really breaking down the
white Tom's grapes are very involved in
this white and I'll let him speak about
that but what you did with the DM is
actually extremely important because I
know I would argue 80% of this audience
follows is watching this right now
because they're more of a business
mindset they're not here to get wildly
educated on the breakdown of empathy one
so this this actually makes this session
even more exciting for me because I
think we can help a lot of people which
is really my true passion
how long have you followed me and then
Joe just I mean for just you your
personal brand probably you know five or
six years nice I'm 37 I'm 37 years old
right so when I started Wine Library TV
you were third year seventh generation
so it was in the DNA but
you didn't know of me when I was doing
while advocating you were you two at
that time did I hit I had seen I had
seen the videos but it hadn't really I
mean to be honest my passion for wine
itself hadn't kliklak
yet so you know but once I did the
research dug a little bit deeper it's
you know somebody providing such
valuable content well all the while
helping their family business I felt
totally so-so
so more recently on the business stuff
some of the other stuff that it uh and
so literally you DM deputy totally iced
I did that in literally two minutes
later I got a response back and the like
three or four days later I met with the
winemaker and then after that had your
team come out visit the vineyards and is
before I even sold you a ton of grapes
and started and started flying from
there so Jon's awesome awesome man when
he called me to let me know about your
guys's big news I was extremist you
could hear the excitement in his voice
and I was excited for him and you guys
it's awesome Dustin or John Nate nor any
of the characters here on video with us
Nate wasn't here but now he left
checking up on you oh wait I think he's
back Nate can you turn your video on and
here we go there's my handsome partner
in crime
hey how's it going are you I'm doing
well Tom how's it going - I'm great it's
uh it's July we're getting close closer
to harvest how you point about this
vintage Tom so it's funny you mention
that this is a it's drier vintage and
for our wine region that's actually a
good thing
so disease pressures are extremely low
there's no no issues at all in the
vineyards right now and with this dry
this drier climate that we're gonna have
harvest I mean anything could change its
farming it open era casino
you know I think they were on track to
have a great especially for the Chenin
Blanc and Chardonnay tit that I grow for
you guys I think it's gonna be an
awesome
awesome call very concentrated very
powerful and a lot of flavor look at
rowdy in the building John didn't wanna
I left out Marty I was gonna join I
think he wanted to join cuz Tom was
giving you huge accolades and you wanted
to get some extra love
it's funny when when I'm being critiqued
yeah I can never be found
yeah I mean when in these business
meetings through the last decade John
when you've done a big problem all of a
sudden weirdly you're on the Cape and
like the service doesn't work and we
can't talk to you for a week but sure
enough a single [ __ ] compliment if
you're on Tom tell tell tell everybody
who's watching to give you a little bit
more love where you know where your
wines can be found like where your what
wines your grapes are in if you can
disclose that or do you know obviously
from a farming standpoint not everybody
here can come and support but is is and
they support besides everybody's
watching right now if you are not signed
up for empathy just so you know because
somebody Samia they unsubscribe from
their empathy subscription that's a Gary
great run I was really just doing this
to support you now that you saw the
company I replied no no no no no no we
have a lot of the backend numbers we
have to hit for this to get really good
you want me to buy the Jets I need you
to double up your subscription so if
you're confused right now and you're on
a three or a six or even a twelve
subscription I need you to bump a bump
if if you love the wine if you buy wine
anyway you buy wine anyway at twenty
bucks
then I want you if you don't buy wine
you don't need to do that if you buy
wine for gifts and clients by the way
Nate I don't know if you heard a story a
real estate agent reach out to me John
you to a real estate agent reached out
to me give it you know what is support
but the twelve bottle subscription
started giving out the wines and one one
like a business account because they
came to the office cuz the person was a
Gary B fan saw the empathy got the
business and the Commission of the house
supposedly the person made his face and
told me how much I'm gonna need that
name to follow up on yeah so Tom I
started aside because I just that's why
I got these in essence what up
can people support you yeah so you can
find my grapes directly that I'm a lot
of disclosed and I'm also a business
partner and founder of the company at
fellow wines calm so that's a 100%
Clarksburg AV a brand founded by myself
and two friends and doing doing trying
to aspire to be be hit happier target so
we appreciate that yeah talk to us about
the vineyard and and what and john
obviously were very close to this one on
the way like let's talk about like
what's what do we what's in what's in
here yeah it's uh so 50% of the blend is
Chenin Blanc which which Tom provided
for us you Troy
Cooper great bottle three anybody orders
right now claim it well triple check if
we'll give you a shout out but if we
double check and you're not in the
system we're gonna shame you shame you
in person and and Nate is looking at the
backend right now I'm typing so he's
gonna look for orders to come in here
nobody wines calm let's do that okay go
ahead Johnny ah so yeah 50% of the blend
is Chenin Blanc which Tom is that fair
to say that Clarksburg EES is kind of
holds its had a lot on Chenin Blanc on
the white side of things totally if you
talk to some way or somebody's from
around the world they would say that you
know outside of the lower our region of
France Clarksburg is one of the premier
wine regions in the world for Chenin
Blanc and if you go to go look up some
old wine library episodes you know Gary
talks a lot about Chenin Blanc's oh yeah
and then another 25% of the blend of
chardonnay which Tom also supplies for
us gives it a little bit of that weight
texture and but I think a lot of people
like and their white wines even if they
they don't know they do and then the
other 25% being VMA which we get from
Boca Shover and Lodi not far away and
what uh mate what how do you think about
this wine compared to last year's white
or in general I mean obviously all three
of us have been so deep for almost nine
months on this you know it's been a long
time on this on this consolation deal
you know how did you navigate
like giving a [ __ ] about the wine while
working on the biggest transaction of
your business life [ __ ] CNBC or
something it's funny
throughout the process especially with
everything going on in the world which
was a whole other stressor for many
reasons you know it felt like I had
three jobs one was running empathy one
was working on the deal and then as a
deal was getting closer it was kind of
starting to integrate with constellation
while there was these other other things
going on in the world so it was a
extremely stressful three months yeah an
extremely stressful three months but two
years running case member Robert I mean
oh we need to you know we got a good
Robert a shout out I like I'm Dustin
puts up the comment that says Moscato
guess F K's right Moscato gets his kid
some of the girls I respect I don't
Robert I've seen that name for for the
past couple years with his support I
actually like it you're one of the few
names that is very familiar to me so
thank you for the support since the I
think since the very beginning
thank you Robert so much yeah that's if
we can get Robert on here before this
episode ends I'm into it cool figure
yeah so it was a while a few months Wow
Garrett Glen thank you for just ordinary
Tom what uh you know what um what's
exciting for you right now in general
like like are you kind of like really in
it now like you're such a cliche story
like seven chittery like every
generation from the second one to the
you the seventh one was like at 13 14
being like I'm not gonna be in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] wine business I'm gonna
be a rock and roll star you know like
like and then like you they set the trap
it's quite often you realize oh wait a
minute Sepik it's actually in your
terroir it's in your DNA and then that
really fun moment starts where you're
like in that phase two okay you got into
it now you're kind of into it into it
are you cut knowing your age and just oh
yeah are you there right now oh I'm
there it's you know I'm president of
our courts Berg winery Brewers and
vendors Association so taking a
leadership role in our wine community
and and for us our in-game isn't you
know successful as a personal farm it's
more about getting the Clarksburg y name
out there and and getting the public to
recognize that it is a great wine
growing region and we could do things
that a lot of people would assume we
can't do with wine and as you I mean as
you guys have seen with our grapes
Trouty what most took you a back when
you were tasting through some of the
components so I think I wanted to really
like the grape and really like been yeah
the juice that he was supplying because
you reached out to us on Instagram and
so yeah bad deck stacked against them or
back for him but I think with the Chenin
in general the the wines are just super
super delicious tons of acidity and yet
they have a lot of complexity a lot of
fruit juicy and then the Chardonnay I
think dollar-for-dollar is just
incredible you know when you compare
that to a lot of chardonnay from you
know down in Sonoma or what it might be
dollar-for-dollar it's incredible
looking at the time Tom what website can
people find you what's the best plug we
can give you before we bounce you out of
here and your beautiful face the best
plug would be visit fellow wines calm
and I'd be it this is right that's right
that is exactly right thank you for
being a part of this story really thank
you excited for you congratulations
thank you brother if I could be a help
to you these guys thank you it's just
Gary at vaynermedia thank you thank you
thank you have a good one Johnny I know
I'm planning on having you here but I
really enjoy razzing and joking and
budding I'll stick around to be razzed
I'm gonna buy some wine from fellow wine
right now though that's very nice
alright let's move on let's move into
our first guest we have some wine
questions Hey
I mean Nate Nate do you go by Nate for
Nathaniel or what do you get you're
coming at did you go by Matt awesome
that real pleasure say hello to John and
mate John name yeah how you doing so bad
good Congrats everybody huge thank you
grandma constellation even with you know
Corona in their portfolio you know
that's awesome man good stop thank you
so one thing I was curious about is you
know year to year how do you decide like
how much of each grape goes into each
blend and you know like from year to
year what determines like the variation
have changed that you put in time so
this is a farming product and you know
obviously since I had a lot to do with
the architecture of the concept I wanted
to call it red white and Rose a actually
this is fun let's get under the hood
trout you're really deepen AIT's a real
good wine guy but like you're a [ __ ]
you're a better wine guy than me
let's just get you know it's called a
spade a spade yeah let's go spades when
I when I kind of like pitched the
concept of like we're gonna make a red
of white a rose a the did you worry
about that did I did that land with you
right away you know that my thought was
it's a farming product we don't a bin
iord we're gonna use my leverage my
relationships my gravitas serendipity
like we just have a time to find the
best vineyards the best farmers and if
one year the red is a hundred percent
Pinot Noir because it's the greatest
pinot noir vintage in California history
cool if the next year it's a blend I
thought that would be fun it would keep
it fresh but but trout me John excuse me
yeah
nothing can you please change John's
name to trout or Trouty
like I don't nobody like your John John
um anyway trout
did did that land with you or were you
more like you know do that do you even
you like it even now like where were you
at with that concept so probably the
first 24 hours or 48 hours that you
pitch me on the idea I didn't like it
and it's probably because as much by the
way this is the story in my life
cuz it doesn't like it and then that
looked traps like limousines hi trout
sorry what audio no I didn't like it
probably cuz I was blinded by being so
in the wine world where everything is
about the single grape variety where it
has to go by be certain rules and then
probably the marketer and brand guy and
me kicked in after sleeping on it for a
day or two and I realized let's just
make the best wine
possible for the best money and that
might change here every year um so that
what goes into that when you create that
kind of flexibility is stuff that you
know that I like in business which is of
the moment I'm not lucked into being a
merlot I'm not locked into being a rose
a made for Pinot Noir I'm not locked
into being a Chardonnay my obsession is
that if everybody who subscribes to it
gets the best $20 wine then I need as
much flexibility on that as possible so
we're out there tasting making
relationships and and honestly that's
why we did the constellation transaction
that puts us in the stratosphere like if
you if all of you thought it was good
now wait to see what we've got cooking
at 20 bucks I mean people are gonna crap
their pants I would've said [ __ ] but now
within the constellation world I'm not
sure it's gonna be a big deal yeah and
engineer speaking of Kenyan geniusly
there's a lot of changing in the
business world going on right now no
what did you do to adjust you know the
pandemic obviously you know like I'm
quick I apologize that Jennifer yes
did he just say rose a made from Pinot
Noir roses are made from red grapes so
it's the skin so like yes that exactly
what I said Jennifer Dalton go ahead
Matt talk about navigating Korona yeah
sure so like you know I'm sitting at
home drinking more than I was before I'd
like what do you want that to reach more
people
that's probably help with sales you know
where do you see opportunity also like
I'm a sales guy actually the first time
Gary I ever got to know you was I work
for the Yankees and yep yep how did the
sales team how did the group like that
cuz I came in hot so you know it knows
great you're fantastic because a lot of
the things you were saying or the things
that I like razz on my boss is about and
just like can you listen to Gary like
this is more successful than you yeah
and so was it two groups after I left
like the youngsters were like yeah and
some of the old guard was like [ __ ] that
guy it was some of it's just like yeah
you know we did the managers like yeah
you know we have our process but then I
go people are like come on man like you
got to be flexible you go with the times
but you know the Enki's are run by the
old guard but at the same time you know
we do such to say you know there's such
a big brand behind because there's a lot
of different things you gotta go
but yes sir you know also where do you
see you know obviously alcohol is
something you can sell a lot more up now
where do you see other sales
opportunities in the business world
growing over the next six or 12 months
Home Office's technology and other
things that play towards home offices
everybody is gonna have a bigger balance
of work from home then free Corona
whenever we get back to normal so I
would go there yeah definitely you know
sports a little rocky right now so thank
you so much for being on appreciate your
time tonight okay I give a couple call
you have a couple shout outs here you
can Nate yeah we have a few looking
sharp and we'll be with you and rut one
minute hey Jeff hey Jeff real quick for
the new empathy subscribers Paul Rubin
Ames Stelzer Craig Ernst Paul Bona Koski
and Karen Wessling love it Dustin idea
wines calm is not down here I have no
idea what you're doing
all right Jeff clean how you don't Jeff
Green I'm a wine director general
manager of program up here in Newburgh
New York up in the Hudson Valley and
currently running a program we've gotten
the Wine Spectator best of award four
years in a row we are currently set to
open another restaurant on the property
a little bit smaller obviously with
restrictions as well with we're all
currently working in but our concept is
always been about value we want to under
promise and over deliver you know when
it comes to wine wine has been a huge
part of our brand in fact most of the
reason why people probably decide is
besides the food and ambiance but the
the wine list that we have and you know
putting together this new concept we
were looking to give everybody you know
certain varietals or vintages from areas
that they might be renowned for but
might not be able to afford but we were
finding small producers that might be on
the same land or might be able to be
declassified but still great quality and
what we've noticed is speaking with a
lot of our parade purveyors directly
they're all expecting a lot of
to be coming in the near future in
different stages which is gonna really
hurt that whole value perception for us
of the European imports so what I was
asking is you know for your opinion do
you think that with these terrorists
coming in because we have a we had a son
ser on a reserve system that I could get
at fifteen dollars a bottle and now it's
going to go up to 23 and probably even
more my dad's dealing with that at Wine
Library it's gonna lead for you to start
looking at regions like King say and
terrain and yeah it's gonna hurt the
upper echelon is gonna hurt that twenty
five to thirty dollar range yeah French
and German wines because to your point
you are you my dad they're gonna walk
away from Sancerre and they're gonna
start looking at terrain and and it's
just gonna change the dynamics and some
of those categories are gonna be strong
enough to become a new echelon people
are gonna start buying thirty five forty
dollar Sancerre at retail hundred dollar
Sancerre at restaurant um and yeah I
mean the tariffs are gonna change the
game so what might do is that perhaps
this might sway their perception value
in domestic wines where or Evernote or
or notice that I didn't say yes yes or
or it's gonna allow things to emerge
yeah to your point listen one of the I
mean I wish I actually have to figure
out how to do some Wine Library TV
literally in the prime of wine lab BTB I
was so anti California chardonnay and
even more I didn't even think there
should be any so many Blanc in any of
California like not over the last ten
years
my palates changed yep and I can't
believe how much I like certain
California from your blog yeah well I
think a lot of the producers out there
really started we don't use that will
want oak bombs anymore they don't want
the buttery feeling they want a little
more lively acid and then the ones that
are on top realized they had to make the
adjustment winemaking and that's what I
was screaming about back then and it's a
really seamless and it was it was
definitely not just me but at the time I
did have a voice and I think it's a
better wine because of it yeah
absolutely awesome well Jeff thank you
so much yeah pleasure to be
success thank you thank you I like
Japanese Trouty trout chef looks like
your hero like some Thai Waimea grabbed
my god that's your guy I feel like I
ruined you you were like a nice proper
man then you then you volunteered try
tell everybody
listen to this cuz I think this is
something that I'm sure a lot of people
who follow me I'm gonna get the emails
and DMS dream it up this way
like what was the first human
interaction we ever had yeah
Boston wine Expo in 2008 came and
volunteered handing out DVDs back in the
good old days Wine Library TV DVDs to
people who are coming by this this train
booth and tasting wines and basically
just put in free work for a couple hours
by doing free work amanda ass made my
pitch do you remember I remember
obviously that event because Kay Murph
was there and she worked at Wine Library
for four or five years and was in the
wine business 750ml probably killing it
she's the best human um do you remember
anything that stands out I've never
asked you this we're like friends now
we've worked together for a long time
you know obviously watch me on YouTube
videos you did anything stand out for
that first day of that just being nice
honestly like I think it's funny like
nothing I was starstruck because at that
time you were like you know didn't
nearly have the following you had but I
was definitely intimidated and everybody
that worked for you and everybody around
there was just super nice and like
bounce me about my background why I you
know why I came there that day why I was
hanging out with them which honestly is
like probably what kept me working for
you for so long it's that you surround
yourself by nice people really smart
people but nice people too it's cool
alright let's keep it going
who was that the Boston wine Expo with
us Brandon Matt cinema k-mers I don't
think he indeed or was there but I got
to know him later too Devin what's good
hey what's going on then I'm I first off
man I'm super height to just be even on
this stream which I'm not even sure if
you actually remember me but I know we
met and I know you're just talking about
with what
when you guys met like so you and I we
actually met for the first time at a CES
back in January this year and we talked
for a little while and you were saying
about how you were talking about you
know just basically a bunch of business
and everything like that and what you
got going and it was funny because one
of the things with myself is like we
were talking and it was funny because I
kept saying man what if I ran into what
if I ran into to Gary here why like
while I'm here and funny thing about it
that's exactly what happened and then
right after that I tweeted it out and
you eventually was saying I think KC had
tweeted it out retweeted it and he was
basically saying that you know I could
you know come out you were basically
saying that I could come out there get
my 30 minutes with you in New York
which was super dope by the way I do
want to tell you that I appreciate that
man for you being a part of that in
saying that so but anyway first off
before I get into my question man I do
want to give a major shout out to you
all as far as what you guys are doing
the new acquirement which you guys is
have man I think it's super super dope
so a major shout-out to you guys with
that for sure man thank you
now one of the questions that I have
yeah one of the question that I have
like me I run a tech channel here on
YouTube called CTO tech and one of the
things that I have to have to actually
guys about in regards to tech what would
you say well how would you say that tech
actually plays a role within the wine
industry in itself Johnny maybe you can
take this one you play a lot in this
game yes so Tech is interesting in the
wine world I would say because it is a
very regulated business especially going
direct to consumer you have to play
within the guidelines that are at a
state-by-state level there's some out of
more out-of-the-box solutions for the
wine business that can kind of help you
build your e-commerce platform for a
direct-to-consumer business we did it a
little bit differently we kept the
customer in mind first we wanted to make
the most customer centric experience in
our website possible we wanted to have
as frictionless buying as possible so we
built our website
on top of Shopify plus and then work
backwards from there of how do we need
to what do we need to build into this to
make a compliant and make it work in
this regulated industry so it's been a
pretty complex process over the past
couple years but tech it was kind of at
the forefront of how we scaled this
business and obviously from the tech you
know just obviously using modern
communication to build the brand I mean
you know this is a wine brand that sold
15,000 cases in its first year and was
all done on social you know so of course
that and then there's in the macro wine
business when I was a kid there was bad
years with wine and now because of the
weather technology and the technology
and winemaking like you I mean
California makes good wine every year
and like literally back
like literally I remember as a kid being
like scared oh my ghoul what if you
bought it you know not no one should
like being like oh you could buy bad
wine bad like doesn't taste good at all
now you people might not like something
but it's not a flawed wine it doesn't
have insect is there's no weather issues
it doesn't have water issues and and so
that is a that's been a huge
game-changer in the wine world the
technology of like weather and farming
and winemaking and the advancements in
technology even my short life are
extraordinary okay do you attest like
this forest like social media to that as
far as the like the growth on how you
guys were able to scale your business to
the level of words that only okay I mean
literally I think the only thing we did
was I was on Fallon other than that had
like everything was social you know like
we did a little tiny bit of press you
know no Johnny Law turd learn you know
listen you know the people we worked
with are my favorite people in it but
like traditional PR and now that was
actually a really fun Devon thank you so
much for being on bro anytime just say
oh yeah yeah appreciate you yeah yes
person a transition thank you Nitra I
think you guys probably realize this
like one of the more fun things actually
talk about this this might help a lot of
people you were important cogs in the
Vayner machine ultimately ending up in a
roll called the office of the CEO
more person team with incredible
Matabele Lada whose huge executive at
the Sasha group Marcus Cruz astok who is
my chief of staff and then you were part
of that team Nate you obviously worked
very close to AJ trout we worked a ton
together you learned a lot from Kellie
McCarthy other things you've been around
for a while
what was what was the biggest difference
between being a key cog in a machine to
then being actually a partner in actual
business John gonna go take it away I
mean it so it's a whole different
mentality it's you know your business
and things matter like they didn't
before you know before you had a support
system before he had a support system of
you know vaynermedia when I started
there was 30 and I think when we left it
was around 700 people so the past the
last two or three years you know there
was a big support system around you
where if something was going wrong there
was teams and infrastructure there to
fix problems and and leaders of
different divisions you know me and John
were leading this business from day one
and thankfully we hired a lot of really
great smart hard-working people to help
us through the challenges but at the end
of the day it's like you know the but
kind of stopped with us I think Gary did
an awesome job letting us run the
business from a day-to-day standpoint
and you know having us use him when
needed but allowed gave us that freedom
to run the business so it was uh you
know was being an entrepreneur it's just
very different than than working in a
system and I think entrepreneurship is
uh is difficult you know I think that's
what I learned in the first six months
of it's not it's not a would you had a
far greater appreciation for my
abilities yeah of course and I you know
I was closed so close to you from a
day-to-day standpoint so it looked it
looked normal you know when I was your
assistant ten years ago that's kind of
what I came into and that looked like
just what normal life was but then when
you actually have to make the decisions
and you're running the business it's a
it's a very different feeling trout I
mean me kind of summed it
but maybe another way to say it is every
single problem is your problem
like if it's an HR issue if it's a
finance issue if it's a whatever it is
especially when it's a small team of
only a handful of people like you're
kind of dealing with everything whereas
you know at a big company when you're
doing cog in the system at the end of
the day you can always go to somebody
else for help and support or you know go
to the CFO or whoever it is and Finance
is their problem or the head of HR they
deal with that once your business
everything kind of falls on you to
figure out so yeah and I would say you
know me and John have been best of
friends for years and so I would say
that you know being able to work on
these problems and solutions together
was definitely good benefit was it hard
in the times where one of you felt the
other person was the issue you know I
think you know what I you know I mean me
and AJ his relationship is different
post vaynermedia to pre not worse didn't
get effect you didn't get [ __ ] up but
different it's just the real life of it
you know there's no way that your
relationships not different you know was
that challenging at first like John if
the first night you went to sleep me
like it's [ __ ] [ __ ] nice fault
like like you know like how did you go
through that when you had this great
relationship growing up in a company
together where he had a what do you did
have a leader like me that really
ultimately did take on all the pressure
yeah you know so now what you real what
you men are talking about is pressure
you know like how was that to navigate
when you had to go through that I you
know it's funny is probably things that
would have taken 60 days or 90 days to
like fester before they would have gone
addressed by normal business partners
happen instead in like five days because
like you just felt comfortable enough to
be like and there were only a handful of
times where I think we actually have
like real conversations where like I
don't agree with that and it's because
we've been come up in the same system
where generally we see eye to eye on
most things but would you say the same
day you're like now I know
actually more than Nate texted me way
more it's like it's trout I'm telling
you it's [ __ ] trap you know no I I
would agree I would say like it should
really get into it though you know
John and I were are are the best of
friends but since running a business who
leads creative at empathy pretty much
puts the hammer down go ahead I'm just
gonna say you know our relation I do
think our relationship changed slightly
over the past couple years cuz you know
every single every single day a work is
you know us together non-stop building
me with me I had you guys dividing and
conquering at times of course cross but
now right you didn't want to see his
face after there's a lot of you in my
life
we got some people here I guarantee John
how you doing we're well Stuart hey so
football as you've probably heard
million times now congratulations on the
constellation deal that is a huge I mean
that's that's huge when it comes to
accomplishing the mission that you guys
are trying to accomplish with basically
making the best wine available what the
greatest price possible so so thank you
very much murder thank you for
contributing to that mission I'm the
owner of the wine on the dine YouTube
channel so Gary wine library TV has been
a huge influence upon what I do because
what I only do is focus around that 15
and 20 dollar and under mark and try to
do my best and tell people what is good
for the value and what they pair with
the sink they need the parrot with the
sink sometimes in my opinion so but I
actually have a question for all of you
this question I'm dying to ask you so
whenever you I have this concept of what
I call a gateway wine which is almost
like like when people talk about gateway
drugs like oh if you try it once you'll
smell well there's a wine where you try
and for the first time you try it you go
man I really want to get deeper into it
so what what were your gateway wines
that got you into this industry many
mine was a tea smoked Pinot Noir from
the Santa Barbara County it was the
first wine
had where I was like wow this is
delicious I want to learn more about
this
I forgot the vintage but I did I
remember us at my friend's house his
parents opened the bottle and that was
like the time that it clicked you know I
probably answer this question a bunch of
different ways in the past but the one
that when you asked at this time I was
like yeah that was it we stirred a
Sauvignon Blanc and the reason being it
was like the late 90s when all of a
sudden I was like 18 years old I
couldn't even drink at the time but like
all of a sudden at my dad's restaurant
you were like do you have Anil insomnia
Blanc and that was the one we had on the
list and then I would anytime you pour
it you knew what it was right away
you're just so distinct so that's the
one for me they like sparked my
curiosity you know for me it was
actually really really really
interesting by the time that I tell you
this story about this wine happened I
probably knew on memory the rating by
the Wine Spectator Robert Parker and
Stephen Tanzer of 10,000 wines off the
top my head because I started reading
about wine and obsessing about knowing
it all at 1516 and the wine I'm about to
tell you happened when I was 21 and a
half I had a mossy 1994 3 1993 Amarone
at a tasting oh and I tasted it and it
tasted for the first year and a half
happy
yeah half a year - year of tasting wine
it all just tasted like white wine red
wine it tastes like wine all this stuff
I read for seven years six years of my
life if I was like what are they [ __ ]
talking about what what scramp I don't
taste goddamn berry this is red wine and
it was the first time I tasted of wine
and said holy crap I got so emotional I
left the tasting to go to the parking I
went back in called my mom in my new
cellphone that I had and said mom it's
literally I'll never forget this mom
it's gonna be okay because I have this
great
that I was gonna know a lot about wine
but not like it and if I didn't like it
I could never really help my dad do what
I wanted to help him with so I loved it
because I like Snickers bars and watch
him a call it and like chocolates it was
and it was like candy milk chocolate not
this like high cocoa count fancy stuff
that's good for your heart and you have
one niblet it was like III KitKat's in a
sitting good and it completely changed
the course of my career that's awesome
yeah so the the other thing that I
wanted to spend a moment on is because I
focus so much on value and in maximizing
the value per dollar for when people are
buying wines first of all I think
empathy is a great $34 so the mission
you guys are doing just stick with it
you you're gonna as you say you're
changing your the world so we wait to
see what this I mean you know the
infrastructure they have from grape I
mean I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try to
charm somebody at Oak alone vineyards
let me put that into empathy red like
I'm on a mission in this partnership
like I I want to make a $70 wine for 20
bucks that would be fantastic and I
would buy all of it but one of the
things that I wanted to ask is so what
are some of the things besides going D
to see directed consumer that that you
feel can also this there's still some
room and I know you don't want to give
away secrets because you gotta you gotta
protect yourself to you but what are
some things that can be done overall
from an industry that I've loose lips so
you know I think I think that um I think
you have to look at certain other arenas
look what happens a when I left and
retired from Wine Library TV and Wine
Library operationally daily Rosie still
wasn't selling at all yeah I mean and so
we have to look in new places Clarksburg
chenin blanc right
maybe it's Idaho Semyon maybe it's
Virginia vionnet maybe it's North
Carolina Cabernet Franc maybe it's you
know a blend of Zin and Chardonnay I
know I'm getting completely ridiculous
now maybe it's wine maybe it's sangria
maybe the maybe the destiny of the
winder
this is infused with actual fruit I
don't know innovation the end yeah
anybody else I want to get some of the
people that have been waiting so we're
gonna go sort keep doing your thing
brother very much
Francesco Belafonte yes awesome he's
doing quotes and in YouTube it's awesome
all right Scott us hey Scott hey fellas
good to see ya
hi first I have a confession to make
this is actually my last bottle of 18
and you'll know why in a second because
my tire I'm from Missouri you will
understand why sitting in a family
members home right now the 19 so I
figured this was a special
identification to polish off my 18 still
loving it and great job grats awesome to
see and thanks for spending the time
this afternoon and evening
so hey I was it was awesome seeing you
mention it you mentioned earlier when
you were doing Wine Library TV about
Chardonnay and I went through the same
thing and so when I was looking for
other whites one of the ones I'm you
mentioned Semyon that you know can be on
the desert east side sometimes but
beyond yay was one that I found that it
just didn't have the butter in the oak
and and all that and so I started
drinking beyond yay but it it has been
amazing to me over the years how it
really hasn't blossomed any I mean I
have like for instance my wine store
which is huge they have to all be on
yeas literally like just outside the
bathroom in the back like I mean that's
it and it's like it is amazing to me how
you know we don't steam or view and yeah
I am wondering why is that why do we not
see that seems like it would be a good
unique it can be dry it can be sweet
amazing cuz there's no Robert let me
explain what I mean by that most of the
premium wines that matter in today's
world were heralded by Robert Parker
over thirty year period the most
important wine critic in modern times
Napa Valley is Napa Valley on the back
of Robert Mondavi
in a lot of ways I was pissed that my
name wasn't Robert Maynard Chuck when I
was doing while obg because it would
have made that statement I just made
even better because there's no Robert
for being a Scott I promise you if I
grew up in a family business that
planted only beyond yay and I caught the
bug the way I did the Union would be the
most popular grape in America love it no
Robert so we got away with any any
thoughts on how we could how it could
nobody knows about it
because if everybody knows about it it's
gonna get an expensive okay we got a
switch subjects in I can I got it and
talk about that but hey so what other
thing I will ask is I haven't checked I
this is actually the second time we've
had a chance to chat I when you were
doing the club empathy back what March
when you were asking people sign up and
doing the call you help me with some
branding in my business immensely
helpful it's been pretty good it isn't
travel so you can imagine what's been
happening post COBIT but it's hugely
helpful and even got the chat with Natan
Trouty back in what that was in about a
year ago in LA and but you you know you
have a little something that might be
more important than meeting me you were
doing an entrepreneur magazine interview
and I had something at that event and I
was hoping I could get five minutes to
your time to get a John Hancock on this
sucker because I mean keep it in the
butt in the bag for you screaming it's
just screaming for a John Hancock right
there you know this is all over Scott
thank you so much for a port brother
thanks guys
good to see you well thanks Scott
awesome let's keep it going
hey guys congratulations thank you my
question is I'm pretty new to wine
probably really got serious because of
you by MP last year
so thank you for that thank you my
question is I'm kind of more interested
in the professional side of it I'm
taking the WS DT level one right now and
I'm eventually wanting to mix various
grapes with Mead and make payment and
try to start a business with that and so
I'm a my question is how would you know
what like value of wines - if you're new
like I am to go out and buy and try and
try to see like that Jacob my advice in
the wine world doesn't say my given
business now is you just got to go out
and try and taste so the advice is
actually just make sure you try
different things yes I could care less
if you go converts for meaner or Rioja
or - matte or Pinot Grigio I just care
that you try different things every time
to give you a shot to figure it out okay
is there would you say a price point
then is I guess I'm getting a like so
you know you know kind of ignore the
bottom of the barrel wines and grape
varieties that you almost are guaranteed
that you are getting
I think workable is insanely under
priced okay
Jon right I think my answer actually is
a little bit different than yours Gary I
think the tasting is definitely a huge
piece of it just taste as much as you
can at all different types price points
even if it means you taste cheap bottle
just to confirm you don't like it but
knowing that your stomach studying with
like WSU tea I did the same thing with
the Court of Master Sommeliers
I actually oddly found that I learned
more just on the internet just going to
like internet wine forums and talking to
people and it was totally free
you learn yeah one library TV yep
sorry you're starting to watch it Jacob
yes I think I did finish
episode 24 actually before yes what's
the biggest in you know I have not
talked to a human being who's this young
who's known me got into wine and now has
got like any this is just good learnings
for me I'm being selfish a little bit
any any weird in slick when you watch
the first 24 episodes are you like Oh
Gary's changed or he's the same or Oh
weird he used to be like any weird
insights that I could learn from
anything interesting I want to say we're
like knowing that those videos go back
to 2006 and being how you act then
versus I've been following you for
probably five years well wait till you
get to episode 55 I'll save you the
secret you hit me back
alright anything to add to that nope
alright Jacob
anything we anything we didn't touch on
no that's pretty much it appreciate you
guys and congratulations thank you
actually just I know we were gonna like
that was gonna be it but let's sneak one
more in view what's going on what's up
brother say what's up to Nate and trout
thank you for putting me on man you guys
pleasure just want to say
congratulations to you all on this huge
accomplishment we Tyler real keen
acquired has been same deal - tano is
the owner entrepreneurs like me I'm 21
years old yeah
is that chest hair is that yeah dude
that's some sexy [ __ ] bro you breathe I
just wanted you to know keep going keep
going
this is something just another thing to
look up to men for you for you from you
but going into my questions cuz I know
you lived on time so when you were 14
what what really drew you towards why
you know and sparked this vision of what
you've now created here with empathy
wines nothing I hated it
my dad forced me to work in the liquor
stores making $1000 a weekend selling
baseball cards and now I have to work in
the store two bucks now we're bagging
ice I didn't like alcohol I didn't drink
a single thing of alcohol in high school
I wasn't attracted to that lifestyle
but what I what attracted me was around
sixteen fifteen sixteen there was this
thing going on where I was like wait a
minute are these rich people collecting
wine and once it became collecting and
that was my love in sports cards I it
completely clicked for me like
completely completely clicked and page
yeah I was just like in the [ __ ] game
it was basically like Frank Thomas Bo
Jackson you look you know you know
Walter Payton became Opus one silver oak
Chateau Petrus and that was it and then
and then it got cool and then the story
I just told about tasting it and tasting
it and then five years later I was all
about it and so it was really cool okay
and so what's been your favorite wine
you've helped create so far anyway I
know you got some big projects coming up
I'm excited I would say the empathy
white last year because it was the place
where we had we had a very strong vision
for the Rose a in the red but the white
we kind of went in kind of creatively
and I was you know I don't know how John
Nate you guys remember it but I was
really focused in that session cuz I was
like really like we have an opportunity
here to do something different thoughts
you know what the white last year we
didn't have anything that it was like a
blank canvas which I think the Rose a in
the red we kind of it's funny that word
that we've partnered with constellation
because the prisoner was one of the
wines that we really looked up to and
wanted to produce a similar wine for but
the white we really didn't have a comp
so going into a line was actually a fun
experience I think how how our roses
have turned out both of them have really
become like a red wine drinkers rose'
which I think has hit a really good spot
in the market so I probably said our
first Rose I I think it was it was
awesome to have a product in the market
finally after working on it for over a
year and to get that feedback from so
many different people that they love the
Rose a was awesome
well thank you so much man have a great
night everybody hope everybody has a
great 4th of July weekend
me trout you guys know how I feel about
you which is that I feel you should take
all your money that you made an empathy
and put into sports cards and I hope Ron
right Nate
I bought it I heard you bought a big
LeBron people to be like you like Nate's
like family like for like real friends
are gonna be like me so what did you do
like you know what what do you do with
some of them he's like I bought a big
LeBron I bought I bought my family a
couple a couple gifts and the only thing
that I did was buy a LeBron proud of you
why are you wearing a sweater
it's the summer issue so sure okay good
oh it's like it's like a new age yeah
Nate's changed post-acquisition I've got
a lot more Gray's as what's happened
yeah you've changed me you've got like
euro cool in like two minutes
I love you two so much and I love you
vaynernation I hope you enjoyed this
hour across the board big shout out to
everybody on all the platforms that have
been leaving leaving a wonderful
comments and I love you have a great
great 4th of July I'm pretty whines calm
we would love the support we got a lot
of wine to sell so that me can buy more
euro shirts